[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check up votre magazine santé
bien-être six mois ci nous parlerons de
la vaccination des tout petits la
sécurité sociale adhésives line lance
une campagne de prévention à la rentrée
mais tout d'abord le premier sujet le
rendez vous réguliers chaque mois nous
partout en immersion dans l'un des
services de l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien de trappes
cette fois ci nous avons suivi le
quotidien du service du bloc opératoire
et le diwan pour les images les passions
se succèdent à limiter son asthme
le parcours démarre ici ils sont
installés sur des brancards et attendent
patiemment leur tour votre prénom
je vais peut-être 206 et je n'avais pas
mangé pas vu sa fille aujourd'hui tout
est millimétré pour être le plus
efficace possible
l'infirmière vérifie les données du
patient avant de le perfuser pour créer
ce que l'on appelle nous voit d'abord
dans une petite perfusion du côté droit
par cette voie l'infirmière pour
injecter des médicaments pour détendre
le patient des anti douleurs ou encore
des antibiotiques sur certaines
pathologies bien précise sur l'autre
bras celui de la main opéré dans 98% des
cas une anesthésie locale du bras est
suffisante en étroite collaboration avec
l'infirmière qui veillent en permanence
sur le patient c'est là que
l'anesthésiste intervient
[Musique]
et je vais repérer les nerfs de votre
droit d'accord c'est comme ça que les
produits injectés sont potentiellement
toxique pour le coeur et le cerveau
s'ils ne vont pas au bon endroit depuis
l'utilisation de l'échographie en
anesthésie les doses ont été réduites
quasiment par cinq par rapport aux
techniques anciennes
l'anesthésiste voit ce qu'il fait il est
devenu nettement plus efficace et la
procédure est devenu beaucoup moins
traumatisant pour le patient et qui
consiste à endormir
l'ensemble des maires du bras en faisant
une piqûre soul et cela lorsqu'on à
columbo axe hiver on se regroupe en fait
l'ensemble des nerfs après sedan par
exemple un centimètre et demi sous la
peau certains produits dure 2 3 heures
les autres ceux qui sont les plus
utilisés peuvent agir jusqu'à 26 heures
cette technique très classique au sein
de l'unité sos mains appelez le bloc
axillaires nécessite une bonne dizaine
de minutes
tous les patients ce matin sont
obligatoirement agents c'est l'un des
principes de sécurité générale en
anesthésie faut rester vraiment
extrêmement strictes et faire en sorte
que sur des actes programmer les
patients et leurs estomacs vides de
façon à ce que s'il ya un accident un
arrêt cardiaque une perte de
connaissance sur un gros malaise vagal
par exemple eh bien on n'est pas ce
risque de régurgitation de vomissements
et d'inhalation dans le poumon qui est
dramatique puisque c'est à peu près de
40 % de mortalité
donc c'est vraiment la grande psychose
anesthésique
j'ai la tête qui tourne chez à l'ouest
mais bon après on espère que ça va bien
se passer
la suite elle se passe son bloc
opératoire la penseuse a eu le programme
opératoire la veille elle a déjà préparé
le matériel et nettoyer le bras du
patient pour éviter les risques
infectieux l'identité du patient a déjà
été vérifiée par l'infirmière et
l'anesthésiste elle est encore une fois
vérifié en bloc avant l'opération
[Musique]
romain chassaing et chirurgiens depuis
15 ans il a fait une formation de
chirurgien orthopédiste puis il s'est
spécialisé en chirurgie de la main c'est
une chirurgie en fait qu'il ya la fois
une chambre froide est programmée avec
de la chance généreuse et de la
chirurgie d'urgence qui est assez
spécifique puisque on est amené à faire
réparer toutes les structures dans une
main vous pouvez être amené à suture et
une artère donc avoir une spécialisation
changer basculèrent ont fait de la
chirurgie énergie sous microscope et de
la chirurgie osseuse la chirurgie
tendineuse donc en fait on doit être
capable de réparer toute une partie tout
les tous les éléments qui constituent la
main au cours d'une intervention mais
c'est pour ça qu'on est rentré précise
chaque jour à sos mains il travaille sur
trois salles à deux chirurgiens
ce matin-là le chirurgien en chef des
opérations plutôt classique
ici il s'agit d'une dame qui a une
arthrose évolué du doigt le cartilage
qui recouvre les eaux a disparu son
doigt et déformés et le mouvement est
impossible il ya des choses rares mais
quand il ya des choses rares et
difficiles en attendant soit se mettre à
deux pour les faire soit s'organiser des
staffs où on va valider l'intervention
entre nos lorsqu'elle est rare et
compliqué pour pour être certain de ne
pas se tromper
c'est une des caractéristiques de notre
groupe c'est de beaucoup échanger
lorsqu'on a des dossiers difficiles
veulent juste après avant de partir
contre les lynx du droit romain chez sal
n'a pas choisi la chirurgie de la main
par hasard personnellement ce qui me
perturbe et en médecine c'est pas arrivé
à soigner les gens savent que dans
beaucoup de catholiques dans beaucoup de
spécialités on accompagne les gens ont
fait des diagnostics et on n'a pas
forcément des solutions pour les soigner
mais les guérir davantage de ses
spécialités la comme l'orthopédie c'est
que c'est une pathologie traumatique que
plus souvent ou de confort et on arrive
à une guérison du patient
après avoir complété le dossier du
patient et rentrer toutes les données
matérielles sur ordinateur la pension se
charge de mettre les instruments à
décontaminer dans ces bacs sur chacun
d'entre eux une feuille de suivi de
stérilisation et notamment les
informations concernant la maladie de la
vache folle si jamais le patient avait
des risques de contamination le
traitement à la des stérilisations
serait différent mais aujourd'hui on
compte 99 % de nos risques
le service du bloc opératoire ces deux
mille mètres carrés avec des équipes qui
travaillent en autarcie complète sylvie
en est la responsable
elle est aussi garante de la sécurité de
tous les patients donc en fait nous
sommes sommes enfermés si on peut dire
ça dans un dans cette ce périmètre nous
ne sortons pas et il ya évidemment des
mesures d'hygiène très particulière sur
le bloc opératoire avec une tenue
vestimentaire avec pas le droit de
porter ni bijou ni vernis à ongles
et avoir chapeauté bavette etc et donc
masque chirurgical
et donc voilà c'est c'est un monde très
particulier
le bloc opératoire à l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien de trappes ce n'est pas
seulement esso et semant et ses circuits
courts ce sont aussi les circuits dits
hospitalisation avec des blocs
pluridisciplinaire répartis dans 15
salles on y trouve tous types de
chirurgies la chirurgie vasculaire
l'urologie la gynécologie l'orthopédie
l'ophtalmologie ou encore la chirurgie
orl comme ici donc on va repositionner
la cloison nasale de ce monsieur qui
était déformée et du coup il respire
très mal et puis on va lui enlever un
gros polype qui l'a dans le c mu et qui
déborde dans sa phase nasa avait qu'il
empêche aussi de respirer après
l'opération pour tous les patients y
compris ceux en circuit court passage
obligé en ss pays salle de surveillance
post interventionnelles l'intervention
s'était passé impeccable très bien moi
je vous surveille dix minutes un quart
d'heure en salle de réveil
ensuite vous retournerez dans notre
service - où vous aurez le droit à une
collation d'état jeunes à bien
c'est parti pour une petite surveillance
le rôle premier des infirmières en salle
de réveil et de rassurer les patients en
cas d'anesthésié générale les patients
arrivent intubé et ventilé
il faut alors les ex tubé et surveiller
leur état en cas de soucis tel qu'un
arrêt cardiaque les infirmières actionne
une alarme et les anesthésistes à courre
aussitôt le service du bloc opératoire
assure 35% d'urgence la nuit
trois équipes de garde ce relais chacune
est composée d'un anesthésiste qui dort
sur place
une infirmière de bloc qui doit être à
moins de 15 minutes
ainsi que d'une aile de garde une fois
qu'on a mis les pieds au bloc ce concept
qu'on est sûr c'est qu'on en sort plus
parce que c'est réellement un monde à
part
c'est une technicité il y a il ya
évidemment du stress parce que on a en
charge des patients qui quelquefois sont
très lourds on peut avoir des urgences
vitales où il faut avoir est très
réactif sur ce qu'on a à faire
et il faut savoir ce que l'on fait des
parcours chronométré pensée repensé et
retravailler
aujourd'hui le service du bloc
opératoire de l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien est connu et reconnu son unité
sol et semant très renommé chaque jour
environ 80 patients transit dans ce
service
[Musique]
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
des yvelines rappelle l'importance de la
vaccination des tout petits une
vaccination qui doit être fait à temps
pour être efficace c'est le message de
prévention de leur campagne qui sera
lancée dès la rentrée pour protéger
votre enfant vacciné le attend c'est le
message de la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines la
vaccination petite enfance comme
véritable enjeu de santé publique à la
rentrée l'organisme lancera une campagne
sur l'ensemble du département où la
situation est plutôt contrasté
on peut dire qu'elle est globalement
assez comparable au niveau national mais
par contre nous sommes assez nettement
en retrait par rapport aux
recommandations du calendrier vaccinal
c'est à dire que les enfants sont
inclinés mais ils sont vaccinés souvent
avec retard
à titre d'exemple 59 % des moins de 24
mois sont à jour de leurs vaccins
hépatite b
loin des 80 % souhaité par l'état un
retard qui s'explique peut-être par la
méconnaissance de certains parents du
calendrier vaccinal
au cours de ses deux premières années un
enfant est beaucoup plus vulnérables à
certaines maladies telles que la
rougeole la coqueluche
aujourd'hui on recommande de débuter
avec station l'âge de 2 mois avec un
vaccin hexavalent qui comprend la
diphtérie le tétanos la poliomyélite
poliomyélite et l'haemophilus qui sont d
un agent de méningite coqueluche
hépatite b et le même jour on pratique
dans l'autre cuisse du bébé le vaccin
contre le pneumocoque qui est un agent
infectieux qui donne des méningites
sévère chez les tout petits ont commencé
à l'âge de deux mois fait la deuxième
dose à l'âge de quatre moyens rappelle à
11 mois autre raison possible de la
situation contrastée dans les yvelines
la réticence des parents certains sont
inquiets et se demandent par exemple si
le système immunitaire de leurs enfants
est assez mature pour pouvoir répondre
au vaccin
je leur explique que le système
immunitaire de l'enfant et
stimuler de manière extrêmement précoce
par de nombreux virus bactéries qui sont
dans l'air sur la peau du bébé dans ses
intestins et que le vaccin représente
une toute petite stimulation immunitaire
qui va être extrêmement bien toléré par
l'accent la campagne de prévention pour
la vaccination des tout petits se
poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de l'année
elle sera relayée par les médecins et
pharmaciens tandis que les parents
seront sensibilisés par courrier ou sms
[Musique]
check up s'est terminé le dernier de la
saison
l'occasion pour moi de dire un grand
merci à tous ceux qui ont participé à ce
magazine tout au long de l'année
elodie moines williams elle patrick
jacques de dixmude et toute la rédaction
et surtout le monteur pascal josèphe un
grand merci à lui pour moi c'est la
dernière je vous souhaite un excellent
été à tous et comme toujours prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]
non
là
[Musique]